30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes
10 minute mindfulness ready to become
[Music]
get filled on the app store or google
play hi everyone it's joanna here
today's workout is a beginner
bodyweight workout we will be doing
fundamental exercises
which you will be using a lot in other
workouts there will be a total of
three rounds which will be broken down
into lower body
upper body and core so i will be guiding
you through each exercise to make sure
that you are doing it correctly
okay so let's do the workout together
and let's have
some fun
before you start any exercise you have
to perform a quick warm-up okay
so i want you to start marching on the
spot to really
wake your muscles up and to get the
blood flowing and also to warm your
muscles alright so just much on the spot
okay i want you to aim to bring
your knees higher up and remember to
land softly okay so it's not a loud step
gentle step and march
good and now i just want you to twist
side to side
so a side rotation again
engage your core okay what do i mean by
engaging your core
i want you to keep your body upright
keep your back flat
chest up and really suck your belly in
and just rotate from your hips
okay so no slouching straight
and rotate good tap
and now give me a twist okay
so stand up cross your knee to meet
your elbow good if this is too tough
just try to bring your knee as high as
you can
again this works on your lower body
as well as your core remember to stand
tall
do not hunch stand tall chest
up that's two more
and now your final warm up is going to
be
a low impact jack okay so just step
to the side keep your knees slightly
bent
and reach your arms up stretch your arms
all the way up and just tap
to the left and to the right
very good few more left and right
and good and just
slowly march it up so your heart rate
should have increased a little bit okay
so the first circuit is going to be a
lower body circuit
we will be doing squats and lunges all
right
beginners if you are unsure of how to do
a proper squat
the first thing to make sure is to stand
shoulder width apart with your toes
pointed forward okay so not too wide not
too narrow
shoulder width apart and i want you to
imagine there's a chair behind you
and you want to be sitting with your
butt down first
so push your butt back come up
and down and up okay
so making sure that your chest is
straight
and your back is upright as well alright
so remember push your butt back first
and your knee should not go over
your toes okay if you're doing this this
is wrong push your butt back up
and good there you go let's try it again
squeeze it look straight
ahead okay look at one point
and back down and up
all right very well done next
is going to be a reverse lunge okay
again
start in a neutral position stand
shoulder width apart with the toes
pointer forward
what i want to do is keep your body
upright hands in the middle
take a step back lunge down tap forward
step back and tap and take a step back
okay
so as you step back bend your knees into
a 90 degree position
and take a step forward good there you
go step back
push it down remember as you push up
push
through your heels your front
heels okay good back
tap back and tap
very good all right let's add a rotation
okay
so what you need to do is step back
rotate and get your core
pull it back step back rotate
and pull it back we will repeat this
workout again
in a bit next is a slight lunge
variation
curtsy lunge which will be working on
your outer glutes
then shoulder width apart now what i'm
going to do is cross your left
leg over remember that your body is
still facing front
step right leg over
and step okay so do not twist your body
this is wrong
keep it forward step back
step and back so the front
foot should always be facing forward
and push through the front heels feel
the work
on your outer glutes chest up
back and down okay arm combo
reach it up pull it down squeeze your
back muscles
pull it down don't worry if you can't
um get the coordination right just focus
on your legs to begin with one more
and back all right good now we want to
combine
both squats and lunges together it's
going to be a squat
to lunge so find your neutral position
squat down step up left leg back
up squat and right leg back
okay got that let's get squat and left
back
one squat one lunge there you go
opposite leg
down and back good job
remember chest up back flat push your
butt
back keep your knees in a 90 degree
position okay as you lunge back one
squat
feel the work on your thighs your
glutes good and just relax
your arms all right very good few more
down back and
down okay we want to repeat the entire
circuit once more
i want you to make sure that you are
getting your squats
right okay this is fundamental all right
so now with um combo all right so squat
as you squat down i want you to reach up
make sure that your chest is facing
forward as you
squat up push your arms back and squeeze
your triceps okay so it's a squat
with a tricep squeeze good
push it back and squeeze all right
squat push your butt back squeeze your
triceps
and push good job very nice
remember that we are also
engaging our upper body muscles i want
you to
really feel the activation of
each and every muscle group
up go good remember do not
lean forward okay good job now
reverse lunge with torso rotation okay
so step facing forward reverse lunge
reach out rotate to
the opposite side pull back reach out
rotate
and as you pull back squeeze your meat
back okay let's do this with me keep
your knees slightly bent
rotate pull it and squeeze your mid back
reach rotate and pull
good job there you go working on
your core muscles your balance and
squeeze look straight ahead find your
balance
remember to pace your breathing okay
reach and squeeze good job
a few more squeeze
without as you come up okay that's one
more
and back very good okay
curtsy lunch all right and we want to
add
a let's pull down as well so it's going
to work
on the big back muscles okay so
find your neutral stance let's go as you
lunge back pull it down good job
feel the work on your back
the side okay good your left muscles
reach up and pull it down
very good remember that your entire body
should be facing forward okay
look at me good job rotate
and squeeze hold it for one count
squeeze
stand tall
[Music]
reach
there you go one last one
and shake it off all right final
exercise
is going to be a combo okay squat and a
lunge
so let's do this together one squat
one lunge and change between legs all
right
and just relax your upper body you can
keep your arms by your side
or directly in front of you squat
and if you can i want you to stay low
keep your knees
soft do not lock your knees
and just find your rhythm
good squat and lunge there you go
good you should feel
your thighs on fire your butt on fire
your legs on fire as well squat
and lunge squat and lunge
stay with me you have few more
one more on each side last one
strong legs and very good
okay take a short one minute break okay
shake your legs out if you need to grab
your mat
because we want to be working on our
upper
body keep yourself hydrated
[Music]
this is going to be an upper body round
okay
so we will be working on the floor first
exercise
love it i hate it it is the best upper
body workout push-ups okay
so there are lots of different
variations but let's start with knee
push-ups
what i want to show you is what you
should not do okay
you should not be piking your butt up
this is wrong
you should not be dipping your hips
this is strong keep your knees together
spread your arms
by your chest and keep your
upper body in one line drive yourself
down
and push yourself up and feel the
engagement
on your chest muscles okay
so down push it up
down and up in order to keep your upper
body in one straight line
again you have to brace your core
so remember to keep your palms by your
chest
and try to drive your chest as low as
you can if you can't go too low
that's okay all right only go as low as
you can
very good now come up and let's turn
around
sit on your butt we want to work on our
triceps or
bingo wings so place your palms on the
floor with your fingers pointed forward
keep your knees in a triangle position
what i want to do is lift your body off
okay
all i need to do is bend your elbows
it's a very small movement okay
bend your elbows down push it up bend
your elbows down and push it up
remember that your elbows should be
facing
back okay it's a very small movement but
you should feel the work
on your triceps bend it push it up
down and up gently tap your butt
on the floor okay do not rest push it
up good our triceps are small
muscles so small movement only your body
weight
but you should feel the work keep going
push it up down and up
okay very good now turn around
lie flat onto the floor this next
workout
i like to call it superman okay it's
going to work on
your lower back your hip strength as
well as your back
strength as well let's start with the
basic spread your arms
and your legs apart all i want to do is
lift
your legs and your arms off the floor
rest it down
as you lift off squeeze your glutes
feel the work on your lower back up
and down okay so do not
look forward gaze on
to the floor keep a neutral spine
and neck good up and
down all right up and
down if this is difficult you can start
by just lifting your upper body up
the mat to begin with okay eventually
add a combo all right the final workout
is going to be a combination superman
with
tricep push-up all right this is going
to be fun
let's work on our upper body one
superman
bring your palms to your chest push up
back down one superman
remember body in one straight line push
yourself up
raise your core feel the shake up
back down palms close your chest
push yourself back up very good
again palms next to your chest elbows
back
push yourself up you should also feel
the work
on your triceps let's keep going
remember to keep your hips
up okay hips up push it up do not
dip your hips one more
push it up and just
rest it out okay we want to repeat the
entire circuit
once more let's start with tricep
push-up
if no let's start with knee push-up
if knee push-up is too tough for you
what you can do is
have a little platform and raise
yourself
off and that will make it easier okay so
spread your palms keep your knees
together
and let's lower your body down and push
it up
okay good job a lot of upper body
strength
but it's going to be really good because
this is going to help you in
other workouts and again do not
look forward we don't want to be
straining our neck gaze
gently onto the floor look down
and up good job and
up very good keep your knees together
and just relax your lower body the focus
is on
your upper body good and now let's turn
around
sit on your butt pumps down
with your fingers facing forward okay if
you want to challenge yourself
you can lift your butt higher off the
floor okay
so that would give you more depth to
lower
yourself down okay so choose your option
remember that both elbows should be
pointing
back do not flare your elbows out
this is wrong point your elbows back
push it up
use the strength for your triceps to
push yourself up do not
use your butt to lift yourself off okay
we're not cheating right now let's go
work on your triceps
up down and up small movement
let's keep going i can feel the burn on
my triceps
really small movement up
here's your breathing find your rhythm
one more
up and down okay good job
let's work on our back okay now
i'm gonna make it slightly more
challenging for you if you're with me
let's do this if not you can just do the
basic superman so spread your arms
and your legs out as you lift yourself
off
squeeze your back muscles squeeze your
legs release
and drop back down okay so choose your
option
you can just stick to the regular
superman or
add a back squeeze back down
and squeeze remember to squeeze your
glutes as well
up engage every muscle
lift off squeeze release back down
and breathe out okay gaze
on the floor squeeze
release up squeeze
and release all right final workout
let's combine it
so one superman pumps by your chest
push it up okay again
one superman pumps by your chest push it
up are we ready let's end this strong
one pumps by your chest push it up
good job okay really lifting your upper
body
off the floor brace your core
engage your core and up
good you are doing
great and you will get
a slightly longer break at the end of
this round lift off
palms by your side push back down
up push good job
one more okay up push
and all right very
very good two rounds down one more round
to go
and the final round is all about working
on
our abs lower abs upper back
upper abs obliques okay so take a short
break
this is the final round we will be
working on our core everybody loves
to work on the abs okay our core muscles
are actually very important because it
helps to stabilize our entire body
so we will be working on the mat all
right
so sit on your bum
bend your knees slightly with your toes
pointed forward the first workout is
going to be a russian twist
this exercise is really good to work on
your obliques so the first thing i want
to make sure is to keep your body
upright chest open okay so do not slouch
chest up and i just want you to rotate
side
to side only lower your body as
low as you can but still keeping your
body up
right if you're already doing this this
is not a russian twist
okay chest up and
twist good
it's not about going too low but rather
it's about working
on the right muscle group so
twisting side to side rotate
your torso good left and right left
and right very good okay now
support your upper body again palms
down with the fingers pointer forward
this is going to be a
single leg knee tuck so keep both legs
straight
what i'm going to do is tuck one knee in
extend it
rest it and down so drive your upper
body
forward as well so drive your knee close
to your chest
one leg at a time good job
there you go tuck it in
and in good so if you want
a more challenging version you can lift
your feet off the floor tuck it in heels
off
tuck it in heels off okay
if your core is just shouting and it's
on fire
you can rest both heels down one knee in
and alternate good good job
there you go left and right left and
right
and good now let's get on to
our palms and our feet mountain climber
okay one of the best core workout and
also cardio but let's start
slow so get into a high plank
spread your palms get onto your toes
spread your feet slightly out
all i want you to do is drive your knee
towards
your elbow okay so drive your knee
forward
towards your elbow so again we are
starting
slow i want you to feel the engagement
on
your core especially your lower abs
and i want you to make sure that you're
keeping
your back flat i don't want to see this
okay
this is wrong or this this is a very
common mistake
just because they want to get it done
they pike their butt up
so back flat drive your knee
forward one at a time keep it slow
keep it strong very good and the final
workout
is a simple plank again
i've mentioned that you have to keep
your back flat
do not dip or do not arch so let's do
this together
choose your option if you're an absolute
beginner
you can start on your knees okay start
on your elbows keep it back flat
and remember do not look forward gaze
look at the floor okay if this is
too easy then get onto
your feet and just breathe
okay brace your core suck your belly in
if your body is
shaking that's normal okay that is
your muscles being engaged and working
as one
unit so suck it in stay strong
all right it is not a plank if you're
piking your butt up
or dipping your hips so stay strong
and back down very
very good now let's repeat the entire
circuit
once more okay let's start with russian
twist
all right so point your toes forward
if you want to bend your knees slightly
remember that
only lean your body as low as you can
without
arching your back okay so i want you to
keep your
palms together and just keep your elbows
out
and rotate left to right
you can always make this workout more
challenging by lifting your heels off
the floor
or by lifting some weights so a simple
basic workout but there are many ways
which you can progress eventually but
first of all
we have to make sure that our form is
correct good keep rotating
left to right left to right okay
very good last one more and good
all right okay now single leg
knee tucks fingers pointed forward
remember that
your arms should just be supporting your
upper body
do not use your arms to help you drive
your body forward okay
ready legs straight out one knee in
and in so choose your option if you want
to challenge yourself
lift your heels off the floor okay
drive your chest forward and drive your
knee towards your chest point
and point okay are we ready
to level it up both off let's go
heels off last 15 seconds
you got this okay a little bit more
challenge
let's go feel the burn on your core
and remember to breathe in and
out one more
and drop it abs on fire that's what we
want
okay now let's get into all fours
let's get into a high plank position
okay
remember that your shoulders should be
in line with
your palms all right so it should not be
too far forward
or too far back in line drive yourself
up
brace your core knee
to elbow okay bring it forward
and just push in to the ground
good job there you go back flat
i don't want to see your bite but piking
up
keep going slow
nice and steady okay the final 10
seconds
let's bring it up a little bit into
a slow run good again
maintaining proper form do not sacrifice
your form good job very well done
one last workout plank
choose your option either on your knees
or
on your feet okay let's go
start on your elbows again shoulders in
line with
your elbows all right palms facing in
have a solid foundation lift yourself
off if you find that this is too
challenging
what you can do is spread your feet
slightly apart
and that will make it a little bit
easier if
you don't want this is too easy i want
to challenge myself keep your feet
close together okay this is going to add
more tension on your core so keep your
thighs your feet close together brace
your core
and just hold it very good
i know this is not where you want to be
right now but stay with me
you have five seconds left and
three two one
and well done
okay give yourself a high five
you know give yourself a clap you have
done so well
if this is your first workout well
congratulations there will be a lot more
workouts for you to
check out and complete on my channel as
well okay
i want you to make sure that throughout
this entire workout that you are making
sure that
your body your posture is correct
and progress from there all right it is
very important that you build a solid
foundation
and really eliminate all the bad habits
all right
now let's end with a little bit of
cooldown okay so
just take this time to bring your heart
rate back
down okay step right at the edge of your
mat bring your left
leg forward just like a lunge position
but this time you get to rest your right
knee on the floor
and i want you to again open up your
chest bring your arms
up and just feel the stretch on your
upper body your back
as well as your hip flexor okay so what
i want to do is
drive your body weight forward
push it forward good and just hold it
okay when it comes to stretching
do not fight against the tension breathe
in to every stretch and that's how you
increase your flexibility
so just breathe
and just hold it for five more counts
and now just slowly drop your arms bring
your left leg back
change right side right leg forward
again i want you to drive
your hips forward the stretch should be
right
here okay and now raise your arms up
and just push forward good job
and just really take this time to bring
your heart rate down
we have done a solid 25 minutes of total
body workout
okay well done
and now just slowly lower your arms down
bring your knees back okay now let's get
into
a downward facing dog so get into a high
plank
again what i need to do is push your
butt
back get into a high mountain
and just walk the dog okay so
bend your knees and try to reach
your heels towards the floor
and really pick your butt up push into
the ground
feel the stretch on your back all right
few more
and now let's just hold it if you can
try to drive your heels down if not
you can just tiptoe okay but what i want
you to do is really
push into the ground okay create
that high mountain feel the stretch on
your back your legs
your cuffs and just hold it right here
and now just drop yourself down get into
a cobra palms by your chest just like a
push-up
push yourself away look up
and remember do not sink into your
shoulders this is wrong
push away feel the stretch
on your abs and your lower back
as well very good
and just breathe if you want to you can
look up for a deeper stretch
and now get into each house pose
so spread your thighs apart knees apart
if you can try to bring your toes to
meet each other
extend your arms forward and just really
push your butt back
as low as you can feel the stretch on
your lats
your arms and also your bum
and just relax okay
and slowly push yourself back up
very very well done if this is your
first workout
well done give yourself a thumbs up let
me know how you got on in the comments
below don't forget to check out a lot
more workouts on my youtube channel
i do have full workout plans and meal
plans as well
if you haven't yet subscribed to my
channel then do hit the subscribe button
okay
and i will see you in my next workout
all the best